Jake: 大家互相看一下谁的红灯
Jake: Everyone, take a look at whose red light is on.
Jake: 白灯没有亮就是
Jake: If the white light isn't on, then...
Lucia: 亮了吗
Lucia: Is it on?
Jake: 亮了很亮很亮
Jake: It's on, very bright.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Jake: 来看一会
Jake: Take a look for a while.
Lucia: OK
Lucia: OK.
Jake: 好看吗
Jake: Looks good?
Shure:  好看
Shure: Looks good.
Shure:  太棒了
Shure: Awesome.
Jake: 好看
Jake: Looks good.
Shure:  来给AI喂点抖音
Shure: Let's feed the AI some TikTok.
Jake: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Tasha: 自己想看
Tasha: Wants to watch it herself.
Jake:评论评论评论
Jake: Comment, comment, comment.
Jake: 这谁啊
Jake: Who is this?
Shure: 陈泽啊
Shure: It's Chen Ze.
Katrina:  呵呵陈泽有点抽象真的
Katrina: Haha, Chen Ze is a bit abstract, really.
Jake:说你整我呢
Jake: Saying you're messing with me.
Jake: 天天小考
Jake: Daily mini quizzes.
Katrina:  哎呀
Katrina: Oh no.
Lucia: 我们现在到哪了
Lucia: Where are we now?
Jake:哎呦 卧槽
Jake: Oh my, damn.
Jake:沙雕
Jake: Silly.
Shure: 成谢谢您
Shure: Alright, thank you.
Jake: 好好嘞
Jake: Okay, got it.
Jake: 哎呀
Jake: Oh dear.
Shure:  掉出来了
Shure: It fell out.
Jake: 哎呀怎么掉出来了
Jake: Oh no, how did it fall out?
Shure:  哎
Shure: Oh.
Lucia: 好谢谢
Lucia: Alright, thanks.
Katrina: 呀好热呀
Katrina: Ah, it's so hot.
Katrina:  感觉比武汉还热呀
Katrina: Feels hotter than Wuhan.
Jake: 会是老板第一个下车
Jake: Will the boss be the first to get off?
Jake: 一般老板是第一个下车吗
Jake: Usually, is the boss the first to get off?
Shure:  不知道
Shure: Don't know.
Lucia: 不是应该先
Lucia: 司机先下车
Lucia: Driver gets off first.
Lucia: 然后给你把门拉开这种
Lucia: Then opens the door for you, like that.
Tasha: 浪费下车
Tasha: Wasting time getting off
Jake: 不会第一个下车
Jake: Won't be the first one to get off
Shure:  万一遇刺什么的是吧
Shure: What if we get ambushed or something, right?
Jake: 对第一个下车第一个被崩
Jake: Yeah, the first one to get off is the first one to get hit
Shure: 第一个下了之后喽
Shure: After the first one gets off
Shure:  保镖
Shure: Bodyguards
Jake: 怎么过去啊
Jake: How do we get there?
Jake: 怎么停在这么个地方啊
Jake: Why stop here?
Katrina: 怎么过去
Katrina: How do we get there?
Tasha: 跨过去
Tasha: Jump over
Shure: 我们只要
Shure: We just need to
Jake: 你跨一下
Jake: You jump over
Shure: 助跑一下
Shure: Get a running start
Lucia: 助跑一下哈哈哈
Lucia: Get a running start, hahaha
Shure:  这怎么给停这地方
Shure: Why stop here?
Lucia: 我好像有一点点晕
Lucia: I feel a bit dizzy
Shure:  给差评
Shure: Give a bad review
Jake: 给差评
Jake: Give a bad review
Jake: 咋整啊
Jake: What do we do?
Jake: 那边是可以走吗
Jake: Can we walk over there?
Shure: 过去
Katrina:  盒马在这个商场里吗
Katrina: Is Hema in this mall?
Jake:那那那过得去吗
Jake: Can we go over there?
Jake: 过不去
Jake: Can't go over
Tasha: 盒马在哪
Tasha: Where is Hema?
Jake: 绕一圈吧
Jake: Let's go around
Katrina: 搜一下
Katrina: Search it
Tasha: 真的可以过去的
Tasha: We can really go over
Jake: 问问吧盒马
Jake: Ask if Hema is a bit higher up
Shure: 盒马
Shure: Hema
Lucia: 那个有点高吧感觉跨不过去啊
Lucia: It feels a bit high, can't jump over
Shure:  谢谢你
Shure: Thank you
Jake: 这个行人还得这么绕
Jake: Pedestrians have to go around like this
Lucia: 哎不是
Lucia: Hey, wait
Lucia: 等一下同志们
Lucia: Wait a minute, everyone
Lucia: 腿长的人已经先过去了
Lucia: Tall people already went over
Lucia: 呵呵是这是是是
Lucia: Haha, is this the way?
Lucia: 是这边吗
Lucia: Is it this way?
Katrina: 这边过去
Katrina: It's this way
Katrina:  在那边
Katrina: Over there.
Shure:  对走吧走吧
Shure: Yeah, let's go, let's go.
Jake: 头盔要不给他吧
Jake: Should we give him the helmet?
Jake: 他跑过了
Jake: He ran past.
Lucia: 哈哈腿长的人已经先过去了
Lucia: Haha, long-legged people already went ahead.
Jake: 跑过了他们
Jake: He ran past them.
Jake: 你也要去
Jake: Are you going too?
Lucia: 不行我今天穿这衣服我翻不了
Lucia: No, I can't, I'm wearing this outfit today, I can't climb.
Jake:你今天你今天不太行
Jake: You're not doing well today.
Jake:下次一定
Jake: Next time for sure.
Shure:  外面大门没有门禁
Shure: There's no access control on the main gate outside.
Katrina:  他刚好有个那个放外卖的桌子 一起
Katrina: There's a table for deliveries right there.
Katrina:  献的300毫升
Katrina: I donated 300 milliliters.
Shure: 我也献过我献过两次
Shure: I've donated too, twice.
Jake: 补一个
Jake: Add one more.
Katrina:  然后差点抽晕
Katrina: And almost fainted.
Shure: 我200毫升就是
Shure: I donated 200 milliliters.
Shure:  100就不流了你知道吗
Shure: After 100, it stopped flowing, you know?
Katrina:  对就不流
Katrina: Yeah, it stopped.
Katrina:  然后害怕你这样倒着你知道吗
Katrina: Then I had to turn upside down, you know?
Katrina:  倒着你要捏那个球啊
Katrina: And squeeze the ball.
Lucia: 啊你们在说什么献血吗
Lucia: Ah, are you talking about donating blood?
Katrina:  当时就献100毫升
Katrina: I donated 100 milliliters.
Katrina:  献不出来了
Katrina: And it wouldn't come out.
Katrina:  然后医生就捏那个血
Katrina: Then the doctor had to squeeze the blood.
Shure:  然后旁边跟我一起去的那个
Shure: Then the person next to me.
Shure:  是一个小胖子
Shure: Was a chubby guy.
Shure:  啪嚓一分钟完事了
Shure: Boom, done in a minute.
Shure:  啥事没有
Shure: No problem at all.
Shure:  下来了
Shure: He came down.
Katrina: 他说到了嗯到了
Katrina: He said, "I'm done."
Shure:  然后看着我在这躺着
Shure: Then he saw me lying there.
Jake: 他们已经上去了
Jake: They've already gone up.
Shure:  哎呦哎呦
Shure: Oh no, oh no.
Lucia: 进吧哎
Lucia: Let's go in.
Lucia: 那个妹子哦
Lucia: That girl.
Lucia: 她在系鞋带
Lucia: She's tying her shoelaces.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure:  我俩给你敞开了大门
Shure: We opened the door wide for you.
Katrina:  谢谢
Katrina: Thanks.
Lucia: 他们过来是不是还待一会
Lucia: Are they coming over and staying for a while?
Lucia: 那就先进去了
Lucia: Then let's go in first.
Shure:  他们选择什么
Shure: What did they choose?
Shure: 他们选择翻墙是吗
Shure: Did they choose to climb over the wall?
Lucia: 什么情况
Lucia: What's going on?
Lucia: 你们怎么已经到了啊
Lucia: How did you get here already?
Jake: 我们还找你们呢
Jake: We were looking for you.
Jake: 怎么丢了呀
Jake: How did you get lost?
Katrina:  系了个鞋带而已
Katrina: Just tying a shoelace.
Shure:  我们我们跟着轩导的步伐来着
Shure: We were following Xuan's lead.
Jake: 哦对
Jake: Oh, right.
Jake: 殊途同归
Jake: Different paths, same destination.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina:  柯达照相
Katrina: Kodak photography.
Shure:  我们之前去那nar的时候买了一次性的胶圈
Shure: We bought a disposable film camera last time we went to Nar.
Katrina:  哦我之前也想买
Katrina: Oh, I wanted to buy one too.
Katrina:  就是
Katrina: But...
Katrina:  我以为我们宿舍毕业旅行会去就
Katrina: I thought our dorm's graduation trip would go there.
Katrina:  新疆那地方就打算买一个
Katrina: I was planning to buy one in Xinjiang.
Tasha: 早知道不翻了
Tasha: Shouldn't have climbed over.
Katrina:  这翻掉了
Alice: This one fell over.
Katrina:  我特别喜欢那种感觉那拍出来的
Katrina: I really like the feeling from those photos.
Shure: 真的特别好我靠
Shure: It's really great, wow.
Katrina:  那你有冲洗出来吗还是直打
Katrina: Did you develop them or just print directly?
Shure: 洗出来了已经
Shure: Already developed them.
Shure: 啊没没洗成那什么
Shure: Oh no, didn't develop them well.
Katrina: 就是导出电子版是吧
Katrina: Just exported to digital, right?
Shure: 对弄电子版然后再是胶片
Shure: Yeah, made a digital copy, then the film.
Tasha: 试送了一个专业
Tasha: Sent a professional.
Shure: 就是你透过阳光是能看到那个影子的
Shure: It's when you can see the shadow through the sunlight.
Katrina:  好浪漫啊
Katrina: So romantic.
Katrina:  你们两个人
Katrina: You two.
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
Shure:  花活特多
Shure: So many tricks.
Shure:  然后我们俩就去两天
Shure: Then we went for two days.
Shure: 一人背个大音箱一人背把吉他
Shure: One carried a big speaker, the other carried a guitar.
Katrina:  真好你俩soulmate呀
Katrina: You two are such soulmates.
Jake: 这是啥地方
Jake: Where is this place?
Alice: 找到一双长睫毛的大眼睛哎
Alice: Found a pair of big eyes with long eyelashes.
Alice: 找到了在那
Alice: Found it, over there.
Shure:  哇
Shure: Wow.
Alice: 哎让ai来一下
Alice: Hey, let AI do it.
Lucia: 不好意思又踩到你了
Lucia: Sorry, stepped on you again.
Shure:  哎呦sorry sorry
Shure: Oops, sorry, sorry.
Katrina:  海澜之家
Katrina: HLA.
Katrina:  海澜之家就在我们家旁边
Katrina: HLA is right next to our house.
Lucia: 甜甜圈中找到一块饼干
Lucia: Found a cookie in the donut.
Alice:哦在哪
Alice: Oh, where?
Jake: 这得多瞎啊
Jake: How blind is that?
Jake: 他看不到啊
Jake: He can't see it.
Alice: 还有呢
Alice: What else?
Alice: 怎么有股有毒的味道
Alice: Why does it smell poisonous?
Tasha: 用这个眼镜去测试你看
Tasha: Use these glasses to test, look.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 感觉刚装修完似得
Lucia: Feels like it's just been renovated.
Alice: 哦原来在这等着我们呢
Alice: Oh, they're waiting for us here.
Tasha: 在车站中找到海澜之家
Tasha: Found HLA at the station.
Alice: 软广
Alice: Product placement.
Tasha: 还真没找着
Tasha: Still couldn't find it.
Lucia: 在衬衫中找到海
Lucia: Found HLA in the shirt.
Shure: 真的在用心的找诶
Shure: Really looking for it seriously.
Jake: 怎么找啊
Jake: How to find it?
Jake: 海澜之家是啥啊
Jake: What's HLA?
Alice:海澜之家
Alice: HLA.
Lucia: 就是一个卖男装的品牌
Lucia: It's a men's clothing brand.
Jake: 海澜之家
Jake: HLA.
Jake:那他是什么
Jake: So what is it?
Katrina: 海澜之家的总工厂就在我们家旁边的镇上
Katrina: The main factory of HLA is in the town next to our home.
Jake: 找他的logo吗
Jake: Are we looking for their logo?
Lucia: 不知道
Lucia: I don't know.
Jake: 他logo是什么样的
Jake: What does their logo look like?
Katrina: 江阴市
Katrina: Jiangyin City.
Alice: 有嘛区别呢
Alice: Does it make any difference?
Alice:让AI来找一下
Alice: Let AI find it.
Lucia: 怎么觉得没有都一样啊
Lucia: Why does it seem like they're all the same?
Jake:都不知道要找什么
Jake: I don't even know what we're looking for.
Tasha: 难度可能是进阶的
Tasha: Maybe it's an advanced level.
Alice: 他可能就是
Alice: Maybe it's just...
Jake:他应该
Jake: It should be...
Alice: 为了给你留下一个深刻的印象
Alice: To leave a deep impression on you.
Jake:可能他就没有
Jake: Maybe he doesn't have one.
Tasha: 然后就一直在找海澜
Tasha: And then just keep looking for HLA.
Jake:对一个一个找
Jake: Yeah, one by one.
Alice: 然后你就特别特别想知道
Alice: Then you really, really want to know.
Alice: 海澜之家到底长啥样
Alice: What does HLA really look like?
Alice: 然后他的目的就达到了
Alice: And then his goal is achieved.
Alice:是这样吗
Alice: Is that it?
Jake: 所以应该长啥样
Jake: So, what should it look like?
Alice: 我也不知道
Alice: I don't know either.
Jake: 海澜之家是自己有个logo是长这样吗
Jake: Does HLA have its own logo that looks like this?
Jake: 还是啥呀
Jake: Or what?
Alice: 海澜之家
Alice: HLA.
Lucia: 他logo长啥样啊
Lucia: What does their logo look like?
Alice: 我就记得一个h一个l他们家的门面
Alice: I just remember an 'H' and an 'L' on their storefront.
Jake:他logo长啥样不知道哇
Jake: You don't know what their logo looks like?
Lucia: 啊好像是
Lucia: Ah, I think so.
Alice:什么
Alice: What?
Lucia: 不知 不了解因为因为咱们平常也不买男装
Lucia: I don't know. We usually don't buy men's clothes.
Alice: 里面就是没有我感觉都一样
Alice: Inside, it all feels the same.
Jake: 对我也不买男装
Jake: Yeah, I don't buy men's clothes either.
Tasha: 那他穿什么
Tasha: Then what does he wear?
Alice:怪怪的
Alice: That's weird.
Jake: 就这个哈哈哈哈
Jake: Just this, hahaha.
Lucia: 淘宝T恤啊你穿
Lucia: Taobao T-shirts, you wear them.
Tasha: 你看喜茶标志很明显
Tasha: Look, Hey Tea's logo is very obvious.
Jake: 这个确实哎
Jake: This is true, huh.
Lucia: 那可能是上面确实有个标志只是没找到
Lucia: Maybe there's a sign up there, we just couldn't find it.
Tasha: 还测吗哈哈
Tasha: Are we still testing? Haha.
Alice: 这有一股有毒的味道
Alice: This smells toxic.
Alice: 感觉在这闻久了要晕倒
Alice: I feel like if I stay here too long, I'll pass out.
Lucia: +1
Lucia:有种没装修完的
Lucia: It feels like it's not fully renovated.
Tasha: 是两位男生推购物车吗
Tasha: Are the two guys pushing the carts?
Jake:行啊
Jake: Sure.
Tasha: 推两辆是吗
Tasha: Pushing two carts, right?
Jake: 行啊没问题
Jake: Yeah, no problem.
Tasha: 一一边采购酒一边采购食材是吗
Tasha: One cart for drinks, one for groceries?
Jake: 呃啊酒要单独一个车吧
Jake: Uh, the drinks should probably have their own cart.
Lucia: 哎那还有小的
Lucia: Hey, there's a small one.
Jake: 推个小的
Jake: Push the small one.
Lucia: 还有小的
Lucia: There's a small one.
Lucia: 啊太小了推起来不好推
Lucia: Ah, it's too small, it's hard to push.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 有那个小把手
Tasha: It has a small handle.
Alice: 这就是小孩推的意思吗
Alice: Is it meant for kids to push?
Jake: 哦是
Jake: Oh, yes.
Lucia: 是把小孩放在里面推小孩的意思吗
Lucia: Does it mean you put a kid inside and push them?
Tasha: 是让小孩推这个车的意思
Tasha: It means kids push this cart.
Alice:是让小孩推得
Alice: It's for kids to push.
Jake: 小孩应该也进不去
Jake: Kids probably can't fit inside.
Jake: 这得是
Jake: This should be...
Lucia: 不会是把小孩放在里面
Lucia: You wouldn't put a kid in it.
Jake:猫
Tasha: 这这小孩坐这
Tasha: This, this kid sits here.
Jake: 请
Jake: Please.
Tasha: 谁
Tasha: Who?
Alice:请
Alice: Please.
Tasha: 谁
Tasha: Who?
Jake: 都行啊
Jake: Anyone's fine.
Shure:  我能上吗
Shure: Can I get in?
Jake: 来
Jake: Come on.
Jake: 给你推货
Jake: I'll push your stuff.
Jake: 给你推冰柜去
Jake: I'll push your freezer.
Jake: 就那个水产
Jake: Over to the seafood section.
Tasha: 西瓜
Tasha: Watermelon.
Alice:西瓜
Alice: Watermelon.
Tasha: 买二得三
Tasha: Buy two get three.
Alice: 榴莲怎么这么便宜
Alice: Why is durian so cheap?
Alice: 是不是该下了
Alice: Is it time to go?
Tasha: 有人不爱吃榴莲吗
Tasha: Does anyone not like durian?
Jake: 我可以吃
Jake: I can eat it.
Alice:没有吧
Alice: No way, right?
Lucia: 不是很爱
Lucia: Not really a fan.
Shure:  怎么说咱们是分头行动
Shure: So are we splitting up?
Lucia: 但没事你想吃的话
Lucia: But it's fine if you want to eat it.
Shure:  还是一起行动
Shure: Or are we sticking together?
Shure:  你把那个图po到那里吧
Shure: Can you post that picture there?
Jake: 我们有分工吗
Jake: Do we have assignments?
Katrina: 发群里吗
Katrina: Post it in the group?
Jake: 我们分几个路啊
Jake: How many routes are we splitting into?
Shure: 对图po群里
Shure: Yes, post the picture in the group.
Alice: 分几个路啊
Alice: How many routes?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: No idea.
Jake: 其实我们戴着这个眼镜
Jake: Actually, with these glasses,
Jake: 绕着一圈就重建了
Jake: we can rebuild the whole place by walking around.
Jake: 就是这个整个商场商场就3D重建了
Jake: The entire mall will be reconstructed in 3D.
Tasha: 场景
Tasha: The scene.
Shure: 所以那天
Shure: So that day...
Jake: 就一个赛博盒马
Jake: It's like a cyber Hema.
Shure:  让我哈哈哈
Shure: made me laugh.
Tasha: 没有网哎 你记得吗
Tasha: There was no internet, remember?
Jake: 每个角落走一圈
Jake: Walk around every corner.
Katrina: 我发了
Katrina: I posted it.
Shure:  会怎么样
Shure: What would happen?
Katrina: 那就分
Katrina: Then we'll split up.
Katrina:  分其实5-10就是你们买菜啊
Katrina: Actually, 5-10 is for grocery shopping.
Katrina:  生活用品的那种地方
Katrina: For daily necessities.
Katrina:  可以你们那就分两拨
Katrina: You guys can split into two groups.
Tasha: 那就5-11呗
Tasha: Then 5-11?
Jake: 分两拨分两拨
Jake: Split into two groups.
Katrina: 分两拨
Katrina: Split into two groups.
Tasha:  5-11
Tasha: 5-11
Katrina:  5-11跟1-4
Katrina: 5-11 and 1-4
Tasha: 你是1-4和12对吗
Tasha: You're 1-4 and 12, right?
Katrina:  啊可以可以
Katrina: Ah, okay, okay.
Lucia: 行
Lucia: Got it.
Katrina:  1-4和12
Katrina: 1-4 and 12.
Katrina:  走我俩去哪个
Katrina: Let's go, which one are we going to?
Jake: 这是什么
Jake: What's this?
Jake: 这是这是什么组
Jake: What's this group?
Jake: 这是什么组
Jake: What group is this?
Tasha: 这是食材组
Tasha: This is the ingredients group.
Katrina: 我我去
Katrina: I'll go.
Katrina:  我们俩去买酒吧
Katrina: The two of us will go buy alcohol.
Tasha: 这是酒组
Tasha: This is the alcohol group.
Jake: 酒组行行好
Jake: Alcohol group, okay.
Katrina:  那你们还要一个过来不
Katrina: So, do you need one more person?
Katrina:  12123456 我俩再加一个
Katrina: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6... The two of us plus one more.
Lucia: 33好了那就
Lucia: 33, alright then.
Katrina:  33
Katrina: 33.
Lucia: 行
Lucia: Okay.
Katrina: 他肯定要
Katrina: He will definitely want to.
Jake: 行那怎么说
Jake: Okay, so what do you say?
Jake:对食材
Jake: Right, ingredients.
Katrina:  他是你们的主主星
Katrina: He is your main star.
Katrina:  组合里你俩选
Katrina: In the group, the two of you choose.
Lucia: 哦对
Lucia: Oh, right.
Alice: 我我我跟他绑定
Alice: I, I, I will pair with him.
Lucia: 我都都行
Lucia: I'm fine with anything.
Lucia: 那我来好了
Lucia: Then I'll do it.
Tasha: 嘿嘿嘿嘿好
Tasha: Hehehe, good.
Katrina:  好反正你还比较懂调酒
Katrina: Alright, you still know more about mixing drinks.
Katrina:  那我们去买酒吧
Katrina: So, we'll go buy alcohol.
Tasha: 对你们三个都是懂酒的
Tasha: Yes, all three of you know about alcohol.
Lucia: 也没有那么
Lucia: Not really.
Lucia: 我我我没有那么懂了其实
Lucia: I don't actually know that much.
Jake: 确实我是一点都不懂
Jake: Honestly, I don't know anything.
Jake: 我咖啡都不喝
Jake: I don't even drink coffee.
Katrina:  朗姆
Katrina: Rum.
Jake: 都没法买啥也没法
Jake: Can't buy anything, can't do anything.
Katrina: 冰块模具
Katrina: Ice cube molds.
Jake: 但是好像食品
Jake: But it seems like food...
Jake: 我也不懂
Jake: I don't understand either.
Lucia: 我可以申请买个水果
Lucia: Can I ask to buy some fruit?
Tasha: 买
Tasha: Buy it.
Tasha: 想吃什么你可以跟我说啊
Tasha: Just tell me what you want to eat.
Lucia: 随便只要是个水果就行
Lucia: Anything, as long as it's fruit.
Katrina:  我想要那个青提
Katrina: I want those green grapes.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈真的
Lucia: Hahaha, really?
Katrina:  我要那个青提
Katrina: I want those green grapes.
Katrina:  阳光玫瑰那种
Katrina: The Shine Muscat ones.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Lucia: 好那我那我也吃这个就可以了
Lucia: Okay, then I'll have those too.
Tasha: 啊好
Tasha: Alright.
Katrina:  你的青梅青梅啊
Katrina: Your green plums, right?
Tasha: 啊这个会买的
Tasha: Yeah, I'll buy those.
Katrina:  青梅啊啊
Katrina: Green plums, yes.
Shure: 这个来公共场合现在已经不感觉到羞耻了
Shure: Coming to public places now, I don't feel ashamed anymore.
Katrina:  我们都是那种视力矫正的没关系
Katrina: We're all about vision correction, it's fine.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 没事他们不知道这个是干啥用的
Lucia: It's okay, they don't know what this is for.
Katrina:  先买酒吧
Katrina: Let's buy some alcohol first.
Katrina: 还有那果汁
Katrina: And some juice too.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Shure: 应该就在那吧 等一下
Shure: It should be over there, wait a sec.
Lucia: 我们主要就是一些饮料吗
Lucia: Are we mainly getting drinks?
Shure: 这都是啤酒不是洋酒
Shure: These are all beers, not liquors.
Lucia: 要不问问他们
Lucia: Maybe we should ask them.
Katrina:  请问这里有郎酒吗
Katrina: Excuse me, do you have Langjiu here?
Shure: 啊成谢谢您
Shure: Ah, thanks.
Lucia: 好谢谢 啊sorry
Lucia: Alright, thanks. Ah, sorry.
Lucia: 招牌烤鸡
Lucia: Signature roast chicken.
Katrina: 呵呵
Katrina: Hehe.
Lucia: 没青柠
Lucia: No limes.
Shure: 这就是朗姆
Shure: This is the rum.
Katrina: 嗯可以买一瓶够了不
Katrina: Hmm, can we buy one bottle, is that enough?
Shure: 够了这
Shure: That's enough.
Katrina: 够了是吧主要加一点点
Katrina: Enough, right? Just need a little bit.
Shure:  咱咱从今天开始喝喝最后一天都喝不完
Shure: From today, even if we drink every day, we won't finish it.
Katrina: 那就买一瓶朗姆就够了伏特加你说你宿舍有
Katrina: Then one bottle of rum is enough. You said you have vodka at your dorm?
Katrina: 你觉得嘞还要吗
Katrina: What do you think, do we need more?
Katrina: 可以买小一点的
Katrina: We can buy a smaller one.
Lucia: 对如果有小就是小瓶的话
Lucia: Yeah, if there's a small bottle available.
Lucia: 我们就可以买两种
Lucia: We can get two kinds.
Lucia: 对但是感觉看起来好像
Lucia: But it seems like...
Shure:  但其实你买3个小瓶
Shure: But actually, if you buy three small bottles...
Shure: 就跟这个一个大瓶
Shure: It's the same as one big bottle.
Shure: 就那种他有卖50毫升50毫升那么小的
Shure: They sell those 50ml ones, really small ones.
Lucia: 哦那种小小的
Lucia: Oh, those tiny ones.
Lucia: 就是酒板那么小那种
Lucia: Like those mini liquor bottles.
Katrina: 诶有的那种便利店有是不是就是这种小小的
Katrina: Yeah, some convenience stores have those tiny ones, right?
Lucia: 对但是那种太小了
Lucia: But those are too small.
Lucia: 如果没有的话我觉得我们买一瓶popular cutting就可以了
Lucia: If they don't have them, I think we can just buy one popular cutting.
Lucia: 不然也喝不完
Lucia: Otherwise, we can't finish it.
Katrina: 维他
Katrina: Vita.
Katrina: get
Katrina: Got it.
Shure:  甜品来尝尝
Jake: Try the dessert.
Alice: 买这个吧
Alice: Let's buy this.
Shure:  维他柠檬茶
Shure: Vita lemon tea.
Katrina:  这喝了确实有点瘾
Katrina: This stuff is really addictive.
Katrina: 喝了又想喝
Katrina: Once you drink it, you want more.
Shure: 白熊
Shure: Polar bear.
Katrina:  还要买可乐
Katrina: And we need to buy Coke.
Lucia: 对可乐可怜
Lucia: Yeah, poor Coke.
Katrina: 这好像饮料都在这一块
Katrina: Seems like all the drinks are here.
Lucia: 这里有气泡酒吗气泡酒
Lucia: Do they have sparkling wine here?
Lucia: 酒精度数会低一点
Lucia: It has lower alcohol content.
Katrina: 气泡酒只有RIO那边
Katrina: The only sparkling wine is over by the RIO section.
Katrina:  可乐买什么
Katrina: What kind of Coke to buy?
Shure: 你说那种香槟那种是吗
Shure: You mean like the champagne kind?
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Shure: 买吧
Shure: Let's buy it.
Katrina: 是要买这么多吧
Katrina: Do we need to buy this much?
Lucia: 可乐我们买瓶装还是听装
Lucia: For Coke, should we get bottles or cans?
Katrina:  你说买这个大的哇他才4块8哎
Katrina: You mean this big one? It's only 4.8 yuan.
Lucia: 就是听装的话如果打开没有喝完就还可以盖上
Lucia: If it's cans, you can reseal it if you don't finish it.
Katrina: 果粒橙咱有是吧
Katrina: We have that pulpy orange drink, right?
Lucia: 对果粒橙咱还有剩了多少两个半瓶
Lucia: How much Tropicana do we have left? Two and a half bottles?
Lucia: 相当于一整瓶大概
Lucia: That's roughly one full bottle.
Lucia: 但是可能喝不到最后一天是吧
Lucia: But we might not have enough for the last day, right?
Katrina:  这个才是主要是
Katrina: That's the main issue.
Katrina:  如果开了的话
Katrina: If we open it...
Katrina:  如果这两天想喝开了到后来就没气了
Katrina: If we open it in the next two days, it will go flat.
Katrina: 买小瓶吧
Katrina: Let's buy small bottles.
Lucia: 确实
Lucia: True.
Shure:  嗨反正公款
Shure: Well, it's on the company tab anyway.
Katrina:  元气森林的葡萄味
Katrina: Grape flavor from Yuanqi Forest.
Shure:  可以买点橙汁什么的
Shure: We can get some orange juice or something.
Katrina:  椰汁
Katrina: Coconut juice.
Shure:  橙汁也好喝
Shure: Orange juice tastes good too.
Katrina: 椰汁是不是只能打开放一天啊
Katrina: Can coconut juice only be kept for one day after opening?
Shure: 好像是
Shure: Seems like it.
Katrina: 谁跟我说来着不能过夜
Katrina: Someone told me it can't be kept overnight.
Lucia: 不知道哎好久没买椰汁了
Lucia: I don't know, I haven't bought coconut juice in a while.
Shure: 弄一瓶
Shure: Let's get a bottle.
Katrina:  想喝就拿吧
Katrina: If you want to drink, just grab it.
Shure: 就是平常大家也喝
Shure: Everyone drinks it anyway.
Lucia: 如果买橙汁了
Lucia: If we get orange juice...
Lucia: 我们一会就
Lucia: we can...
Lucia: 挑一个气泡酒吧
Lucia: choose a sparkling wine.
Katrina:  可以呀
Katrina: Sure.
Katrina:  这样就可以这样就可以调柠檬茶了
Katrina: That way we can make lemon tea too.
Katrina: 都行啊
Katrina: Anything's fine.
Katrina: 那那椰汁买瓶小的
Katrina: Let's get a small bottle of coconut juice then.
Lucia: 也行
Lucia: That's fine.
Katrina:  大瓶的怕都喝中毒了
Katrina: I'm afraid we'll get sick from drinking a big bottle.
Lucia: 椰汁取决于大家想不想试试考拉的如果
Lucia: Whether we get coconut juice depends on if people want to try Koala's.
Katrina: 到时候我每个味道都尝一口
Katrina: I'll taste a bit of every flavor.
Lucia: 有人喜欢喝的话
Lucia: If someone likes it...
Lucia: 百威
Lucia: Budweiser.
Katrina: 北冰洋
Katrina: Beibingyang.
Lucia: 小心
Lucia: Be careful.
Lucia: 对这的话
Lucia: In that case...
Katrina: 这是葡萄酒
Katrina: This is wine.
Lucia: 雷司令雷司令甜度会更高一些
Lucia: The Riesling has a higher sweetness.
Shure:  起泡酒
Shure: Sparkling wine.
Lucia: 对这个是起泡酒
Lucia: Yes, this is sparkling wine.
Shure:  最后一天开瓶香槟
Shure: Let's open a bottle of champagne on the last day.
Shure:  好吧卧槽
Shure: Alright, damn.
Katrina: 不知道以为
Katrina: If you didn't know, you'd think...
Lucia: 这个其实也没有很贵吧
Lucia: Actually, this isn't very expensive, right?
Katrina:  对我感觉这价格不是很贵
Katrina: Yeah, I don't think the price is very high.
Shure: 对98而已
Shure: Yeah, it's only 98.
Lucia: 能行
Lucia: Sounds good.
Lucia: 这个是这个是
Lucia: This is, this is...
Lucia: rose
Lucia: Rosé.
Lucia: 底下是红葡萄酒
Lucia: The bottom is red wine.
Lucia: 就这一种气泡酒啊
Lucia: This is the only kind of sparkling wine?
Shure:  上面也是
Shure: The top too.
Lucia: 上面这个是蒙耶
Lucia: The top one is Monge.
Lucia: 蒙耶的山东就是这个
Lucia: Monge's Shandong is this one.
Lucia: 很贵的吧应该
Lucia: It should be very expensive, right?
Shure: 没有188
Shure: No, it's 188.
Lucia: 哦旁边这比较贵
Lucia: Oh, the one next to it is more expensive.
Lucia: 对哈哈
Lucia: Yes, haha.
Shure: 不行就这个吧
Shure: If not, let's just get this one.
Lucia: 我们能不能
Lucia: Can we...
Katrina: 够了平时也可以喝嘛
Katrina: It's enough, we can drink it normally too.
Lucia: 喝完如果如果大家觉得OK的话可以可以试试
Lucia: If we finish it and everyone thinks it's okay, we can try it.
Shure: 对这个其实其实度数很低
Shure: Yeah, actually the alcohol content is very low.
Lucia: 因为起泡
Lucia: Because it's sparkling...
Lucia: 因为起泡酒加那个柳橙汁
Lucia: Because sparkling wine mixed with orange juice...
Lucia: 是很经典的一款鸡尾酒
Lucia: Is a very classic cocktail.
Katrina: 拿下
Katrina: Let's get it.
Lucia: 如果大家想试试可以试试
Lucia: If everyone wants to try, we can try it.
Katrina: 拿下拿下
Katrina: Let's get it, let's get it.
Shure: 公款吃喝天呐这辈子能有几回啊
Shure: Eating and drinking on public funds, how many times can this happen in a lifetime?
Shure:  而且连着七天吃喝家人们
Shure: And for seven days straight, everyone.
Tasha: 这个是便
Tasha: This is...
Shure: 啊不行这是不都记住了我靠
Shure: Oh no, isn't this memorable? Damn.
Lucia: 没事他们应该会把这一段剪掉的放心吧
Lucia: No worries, they should edit this part out, don't worry.
Lucia: 我猜的
Lucia: I'm guessing.
Katrina:  结束了杨老板才看
Katrina: Jake will only see it after it's over.
Shure: 杨老板我明天就带着眼镜跑路
Shure: Jake, I'll run away with my glasses tomorrow.
Lucia: 好想喝
Lucia: I really want a drink.
Shure: 我卖眼镜直接倒手一卖
Shure: I sell glasses and flip them for a profit.
Shure: 8000美刀
Shure: 8000 bucks.
Katrina:  8,000美刀到手
Katrina: 8,000 bucks in hand.
Shure: 而且还是属于商密这种
Shure: And it's still considered confidential.
Shure: 就是还没开放的版本
Shure: It's an unreleased version.
Katrina: 你在开黑一点价格
Katrina: You're undervaluing it.
Katrina:  有人是想把这眼镜拿来一万美刀拿来
Katrina: Some people want to buy these glasses for 10,000 bucks.
Shure: 一万美刀我靠
Shure: 10,000 bucks, damn.
Lucia: 这眼镜不是你有一万美刀也不一定能买得到嘛
Lucia: Even with 10,000 bucks, you might not be able to buy them.
Lucia: 好像他只给高校
Lucia: Seems like they're only for universities.
Lucia: 就是分发一些用来做实验
Lucia: They distribute some for experiments.
Lucia: 所以
Lucia: So...
Lucia: 哈哈谈话内容逐渐危险
Lucia: Haha, the conversation's getting risky.
Shure:  刚是不是还说买个桃汁
Shure: Didn't we just talk about buying peach juice?
Shure:  会员那个桃汁哦
Shure: That member's peach juice.
Lucia: 我看一眼这是哎遇到了
Lucia: Let me check, oh, here it is.
Katrina:  遇到了
Katrina: Found it.
Jake: 您家哦还不是一家
Jake: Your place, huh? Not just one place.
Katrina: 饮料这也有
Katrina: They have drinks here too.
Lucia: 试试吧
Lucia: Let's try it.
Jake: 哈喽
Jake: Hello.
Lucia:  哈喽
Lucia: Hello.
Shure:  你平时喝酒吗
Shure: Do you drink alcohol?
Katrina: 怎么没看见那个维维
Katrina: Why didn't I see that Weiwei?
Lucia: 你问我们俩的谁
Lucia: Who are you asking about?
Lucia: 里面的谁
Lucia: Who inside?
Shure: 你们俩
Shure: Both of you.
Jake: 我来瞅瞅你们买的啥
Jake: Let me see what you bought.
Shure: 平时喝酒吗
Jake: 你们看起来进度一般了
Jake: You seem to be making slow progress.
Katrina:  嗯没找到饮料
Katrina: Yeah, couldn't find the drinks.
Shure:  是要我们大买特买那个意思吗
Shure: Are you suggesting we buy a lot?
Lucia: 哎他们他们买了椰子水
Lucia: Hey, they bought coconut water.
Lucia: 刚好我们不用买了啊
Lucia: So we don't need to buy it now.
Katrina:  哦他们买了椰子水
Katrina: Oh, they bought coconut water.
Katrina:  是要用椰奶还是椰子水啊
Katrina: Should we use coconut milk or coconut water?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Lucia: 呃其实最好是椰奶
Lucia: Uh, actually, coconut milk is best.
Lucia: 但是咱们也没有那么那个啥嘛
Lucia: But we don't have that much, do we?
Lucia: 那么抠细节
Lucia: Such attention to detail.
Shure:  椰奶和椰子水完全两个味啊
Shure: Coconut milk and coconut water taste totally different.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yeah.
Lucia: 再自己加一点
Lucia: Add a little more yourself.
Katrina:  咋没找到那个饮料呢
Katrina: Why can't we find that drink?
Katrina:  我刚说饮料肯定有一点的
Katrina: I just said there must be some drinks.
Shure: 肯定有椰奶
Shure: There must be coconut milk.
Shure: 盒马的东西还是比较全养乐多
Shure: Hema has pretty much everything, including Yakult.
Katrina:  养乐多
Katrina: Yakult.
Katrina:  养乐多要买两排吧
Katrina: Should we buy two packs of Yakult?
Katrina:  这感觉我们自己偷偷喝都喝掉
Katrina: Feels like we'd secretly drink it all ourselves.
Shure:  买3排
Shure: Buy three packs.
Shure:  这低糖的
Shure: This one's low-sugar.
Katrina:  低糖嗯
Katrina: Low-sugar, huh.
Katrina:  图个心里
Katrina: Just for peace of mind.
Shure:  有一次喝
Shure: Once I drank...
Katrina:  味道差不多
Katrina: Tastes about the same.
Shure:  喝养乐多兑那个那什么葡萄汁然后
Shure: I drank Yakult mixed with, uh, grape juice and...
Shure:  伏特加第二天进医院
Shure: Vodka. Ended up in the hospital the next day.
Katrina:  为什么啊
Katrina: Why?
Alice: 买两个
Alice: Buy two.
Shure:  就急性肠胃炎
Shure: Got acute gastroenteritis.
Shure:  我可能就是
Shure: I might have a slight lactose intolerance.
Shure: 略微有一点乳糖不耐
Shure: Plus, the weather changed drastically those days.
Shure:  然后再加上那两天
Shure: And then...
Shure: 变天就是气候变化特别大
Shure: Just the climate change was huge.
Katrina: 葡萄汁呢我直接问他吧
Katrina: The grape juice, let me ask him directly.
Lucia: 乐视出游快线
Lucia: LeTV travel express.
Shure:  然后之后就闻到那个养乐多味道就开始ptsd
Shure: And then after that, whenever I smell Yakult, I get PTSD.
Katrina: 你好请问元气森林葡萄在哪
Katrina: Hi, do you know where the Genki Forest grape is?
Lucia: 当然
Lucia: Of course.
Katrina:  汇源果汁也没看见
Katrina: I didn't see Huiyuan juice either.
Katrina:  呃他说都在酒水那呀
Katrina: Uh, he said all the drinks are by the alcohol section.
Shure:  都在酒水那边吗
Shure: They're all by the alcohol section?
Katrina:  对啊，他说元气森林在酒水那
Katrina: Yeah, he said the Genki Forest drinks are by the alcohol.
Katrina:  他不会不全
Katrina: They can't be incomplete.
Katrina:  不全就随便买葡萄汁
Katrina: If they are, just buy any grape juice.
Shure:  我们真的按计划来的吗
Shure: Are we really following the plan?
Shure:  p人哎不是j人
Shure: P people, not J people.
Katrina:  是在买这些啊
Katrina: We're buying these, right?
Shure:  我们要不买点火锅底料
Shure: How about we buy some hot pot base?
Shure:  然后哪天晚上整一顿吧
Shure: And then one night we can have a hot pot feast?
Katrina: 也可以
Katrina: Sounds good.
Lucia: 对咱那天说吃火锅来
Lucia: Yeah, we talked about having hot pot that day.
Lucia: 就今天中午
Lucia: How about this noon?
Katrina: 可以啊
Katrina: Sure.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 说哪天做火锅来着
Lucia: When did we say we were going to have hot pot again?
Shure:  这清单卖的东西j人
Shure: This list... does it sell people?
Shure:  能买吗
Shure: Can you buy it?
Katrina:  可以可以哈哈哈
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, haha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure:  我主要怕你结账时候崩溃
Shure: I'm just worried you'll freak out at the checkout.
Shure:  你们为什么买清单外的东西
Shure: Why did you buy things not on the list?
Katrina:  有预算的话肯定就不行
Katrina: If there was a budget, we definitely couldn't.
Katrina:  没有预算
Katrina: There's no budget.
Katrina: 或者说预算不需要我考虑
Katrina: Or rather, I don't need to worry about the budget.
Katrina:  你们是不是有人不能吃辣呀
Katrina: Is there anyone who can't eat spicy food?
Shure: 菌汤的那个然后再来个牛油的
Shure: Let's get a mushroom soup base and then a beef tallow one.
Katrina:  鸳鸯锅哦
Katrina: A split pot.
Shure:  咱们没有鸳鸯锅耶
Shure: We don't have a split pot.
Katrina:  也那搞两锅呗
Katrina: Then let's just use two pots.
Shure:  搞两个6个人搞两个锅
Shure: Two pots for six people?
Katrina:  有有两个锅吗
Katrina: Do we have two pots?
Shure:  啊有
Shure: Yeah, we do.
Shure:  那肯定有
Shure: Definitely.
Shure:  随便拿一个
Shure: Just grab one.
Shure:  这一看就很牛逼的样子
Shure: This one looks pretty awesome.
Shure:  就拿这个
Shure: Let's take this.
Shure:  走
Shure: Let's go.
Katrina:  怎么没看见元气森林
Katrina: Why can't I find Yuanqi Forest?
Shure: 希望你们不要背着我偷偷吃火锅
Shure: I hope you guys don't secretly eat hot pot without me.
Shure: 不要今晚吃好吗
Shure: Not tonight, okay?
Lucia: 今晚应该来不及吃放心吧
Lucia: We probably won't have time tonight, don't worry.
Katrina: 葡萄水
Katrina: Grape soda.
Katrina:  对没看到
Katrina: Yeah, I didn't see it.
Shure:  没看到
Shure: Didn't see it.
Katrina:  那汇源果汁呢
Katrina: What about Huiyuan juice?
Shure:  那就买那个盒马的桃汁也一样
Shure: Let's just buy Hema's peach juice, it's the same.
Katrina:  那就买个桃汁
Katrina: Okay, let's get the peach juice.
Katrina:  买个葡萄汁算了
Katrina: Just buy some grape juice.
Katrina:  他们是不是有什么
Katrina: Do they have something...
Shure: 买点苏打水
Shure: Buy some soda water.
Katrina: 品牌利益
Katrina: Brand benefits?
Shure: 然后苏打苏打水然后和那什么
Shure: Then soda, soda water, and what else...
Shure: 就一个道理的
Shure: It's the same logic.
Katrina: 苏打水和什么
Katrina: Soda water and what?
Shure: 苏打水和葡萄汁那不就是
Shure: Soda water and grape juice, isn't that...
Shure:  元气森林吗
Shure: Genki Forest?
Lucia: 可乐味
Lucia: Cola flavor.
Katrina:  啊这是胡萝卜跟葡萄算了
Katrina: Ah, this is carrot and grape, forget it.
Katrina: 这有点
Katrina: This is a bit...
Shure: 其实一样
Shure: Actually the same.
Katrina: 葡萄味道在里面
Katrina: There's a grape taste in it.
Shure: 那你买那个美汁源的那个葡萄汁
Shure: Then you buy that Minute Maid grape juice.
Katrina: 美汁源他说没有啊盒马没有美汁源
Katrina: Minute Maid, they said there's none. Hema doesn't have Minute Maid.
Shure: 不还有果粒橙嘛
Shure: There's still Pulpy Orange, right?
Katrina:  哦不是说错了
Katrina: Oh no, I said it wrong.
Katrina:  没有汇源
Katrina: There's no Huiyuan.
Katrina: 买它这是桑葚这也不是葡萄
Katrina: Buying this, this is mulberry, it's not grape.
Katrina: 葡萄汁呢
Katrina: Where's the grape juice?
Shure: 把 j人掰直随便拿
Shure: Just grab whatever, it's all the same.
Shure: 就这个一样的
Shure: This one, it's the same.
Katrina: 但他有胡萝卜的味道诶
Katrina: But it tastes like carrot!
Shure: 没事不好喝就干喝了吧
Shure: Never mind, if it's not good, just drink it.
Katrina: 可乐维他柠檬葡萄汁养乐多西柚味水溶C
Katrina: Coke, Vita Lemon, grape juice, Yakult, grapefruit flavored Vitamin C drink.
Shure: 哪有苏打水
Shure: Where's the soda water?
Shure: 苏打水
Shure: Soda water.
Katrina: 是要哪个啊椰奶啊桃跟西柚味
Katrina: Which one to get? Coconut milk, peach, and grapefruit flavor?
Shure: 椰奶这不是椰奶
Shure: Coconut milk, this isn't coconut milk.
Katrina: 桃跟西柚味
Katrina: Peach and grapefruit flavor.
Katrina: 椰奶拿这个
Katrina: Take this coconut milk.
Lucia: 这个不是太大了吗
Lucia: Isn't this too big?
Katrina: 没有小的呀
Katrina: There's no smaller one.
Katrina:  我靠他两罐起卖
Katrina: Damn, they're sold in pairs.
Lucia: 就是为什么会两罐起卖啊
Lucia: Why are they sold in pairs?
Katrina: 买一送一吗
Katrina: Buy one, get one free?
Lucia: 我查一下可瓦达是用椰汁还是是用椰奶
Lucia: Let me check if Kavda uses coconut water or coconut milk.
Katrina:  桃跟西柚味
Katrina: Peach and grapefruit flavor.
Shure:  这什么水啊 9.3ph
Shure: What kind of water is this? 9.3 pH?
Shure: 快问快答ph9.3是
Shure: Quick question, what is pH 9.3?
Katrina:  我没学化学
Katrina: I didn't study chemistry.
Katrina: 我从高二就没学化学
Katrina: I haven't studied chemistry since my second year of high school.
Katrina:  我们江苏只学两门
Katrina: In Jiangsu, we only study two subjects.
Katrina:  我是最后一年江苏卷
Katrina: I was in the last year for the Jiangsu exam format.
Katrina:  我就考300多分
Katrina: I only scored over 300 points.
Shure:  满分多少500
Shure: Out of how many? 500?
Lucia: 似乎是
Lucia: Seems like it.
Katrina: 480
Katrina: 480.
Lucia: 按照网上的说的是椰奶
Lucia: According to what it says online, it's coconut milk.
Lucia: 椰奶或者椰浆的意思
Lucia: It means either coconut milk or coconut cream.
Shure:  他是这个椰子牌椰汁我从小喝到大
Shure: This coconut brand coconut juice, I've been drinking it since I was a kid.
Shure:  应该也可以
Shure: It should be okay too.
Lucia: 应该也行那个感觉比较像椰浆
Lucia: It should be fine; that one feels more like coconut cream.
Lucia: 椰汁应该那种比较清的是椰汁吧
Lucia: The clearer one should be the coconut juice.
Katrina: 冷藏区
Katrina: Refrigerated section.
Shure:  coffee
Shure: Coffee.
Shure:  你是不是要coffee来着
Shure: Do you want coffee?
Shure: 你买一条吧万一那什么呢
Shure: Buy a pack just in case.
Lucia: 可以我感觉我现在已经挺困的了
Lucia: Sure, I feel like I'm already quite tired.
Katrina: 西柚味的话拿哪个代替啊
Katrina: If it's grapefruit flavor, what can we use instead?
Shure: 西柚这个也行
Shure: This grapefruit one works too.
Katrina: 红的行
Katrina: The red one is fine.
Shure:  j人已经
Shure: People are already...
Shure:  快快那什么了
Shure: Hurry up and do something.
Katrina:  居然找不到这几个这么长见的
Katrina: Can't believe we can't find these common things.
Shure:  快麻了
Shure: I'm getting numb.
Shure:  所有的全是代替的
Shure: Everything is a substitute.
Shure:  除了养乐多
Shure: Except Yakult.
Lucia: 没关系我们可以调整一下计划
Lucia: It's okay, we can adjust our plan.
Shure: 都一个味咱就喝吧
Shure: They all taste the same, let's just drink.
Katrina:  桃
Katrina: Peach.
Shure:  一喝一个不吱声
Shure: Drink one and don't say a word.
Katrina:  一喝一个中毒啊
Katrina: Drink one and get poisoned.
Shure:  这晚上你就试试
Shure: Try it tonight.
Katrina:  桃汁呢那
Katrina: What about peach juice?
Katrina:  哦那边还有一个
Katrina: Oh, there's one over there.
Katrina:  感觉盒马也不是特别大哎
Katrina: Feels like Hema isn't that big either.
Katrina:  呀呀呀
Katrina: Ah ah ah.
Shure:  啊鸡蛋他们买了吗
Shure: Did they buy eggs?
Katrina: 他们应该会买
Katrina: They should buy it.
Shure:  生食鸡蛋这种
Shure: Raw eggs, that kind of thing.
Lucia: 他们应该买了吧
Lucia: I think they bought it, right?
Lucia: 或许
Lucia: Maybe.
Lucia: 看到他们了
Lucia: I see them.
Shure: 你们买鸡蛋了吗
Shure: Did you guys buy eggs?
Shure:  你们买鸡蛋了吗
Shure: Did you buy eggs?
Jake: 买鸡蛋了
Jake: We bought eggs.
Jake: 买了无菌蛋
Jake: We bought sterile eggs.
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK.
Shure:  我们买了两个火锅底料
Shure: We bought two hotpot bases.
Jake: 火锅底料
Jake: Hotpot base.
Katrina: 没有桃汁啊
Katrina: No peach juice?
Shure:  完了我们j人崩溃了
Shure: Oh no, our J person is having a meltdown.
Jake: 我们好像我们我们分到了个
Jake: It seems like we got assigned some...
Shure: 气的跳脚脚了
Shure: They're jumping up and down in anger.
Jake: 什么奇怪的任务来着
Jake: Some strange task.
Alice: 什么
Alice: What?
Shure: 扎死人
Shure: It's killing me.
Alice: 美纹纸
Alice: Masking tape.
Katrina: 普通的品牌都没有吗
Katrina: Not even regular brands?
Jake:美纹纸美纹纸是什么东西
Jake: What's masking tape?
Alice:美纹纸这有吗
Alice: Do they have masking tape here?
Katrina:  美文纸美文纸
Katrina: Masking tape, masking tape.
Lucia:美纹纸这这里面能买到吗
Lucia: Can we buy masking tape here?
Jake: 美纹纸是什么东西
Jake: What's masking tape?
Katrina: 就贴墙上不留痕的那贴纸
Katrina: It's the tape you stick on walls without leaving marks.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice:再买两个
Alice: Buy two more.
Katrina:  跟那个美纹纸很便宜
Katrina: And that masking tape is cheap.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 嗯啊我觉得文具店也会有
Tasha: Yeah, I think the stationery store might have it too.
Katrina: 冰块模具还没买
Katrina: We haven't bought the ice cube molds yet.
Katrina:  但这有我们感觉全是买吃的地方
Katrina: But it feels like this place is all about food.
Shure:  够呛呦冰块模具
Shure: Ice cube molds might be hard to find.
Katrina: 盒马是不是主营饮食啊
Katrina: Isn't Hema mainly for food?
Alice:要不然我们买大白菜吧
Alice: How about we buy some napa cabbage?
Tasha: 好呀
Tasha: Sure.
Shure: 对生鲜类
Shure: Yeah, fresh produce.
Alice:然后我们把嫩的部分给它扔进去
Alice: And then we can throw the tender parts in.
Katrina: 那就直接叫美团外送吧
Katrina: Then let's just order from Meituan.
Tasha: 可以呀 可以
Tasha: Sure, sure.
Katrina: 冰块模具打孔器彩笔
Katrina: Ice cube molds, hole punch, colored pens.
Shure:  或者直接美团买冰得了
Shure: Or we could just order ice from Meituan.
Katrina:  美团可以买冰吗
Katrina: Can you really order ice from Meituan?
Katrina: 他运过来不会化吗
Katrina: Won't it melt during delivery?
Shure:  可以的
Shure: It can be done.
Katrina:  柠檬片没买
Katrina: Didn't buy lemon slices.
Lucia: 哦是要那种
Lucia: Oh, do you need those?
Lucia: 就是加工过的柠檬片还是鲜柠檬那种
Lucia: Do you need processed lemon slices or fresh lemons?
Shure: 直接买柠檬然后切了就行咱们有刀
Shure: Just buy lemons and slice them; we have a knife.
Katrina: 直接买柠檬也行
Katrina: Buying lemons works too.
Shure:  先买柠檬
Shure: Let's just buy lemons first.
Shure:  你看哎
Shure: Look here.
Shure:  什么来什么啊
Shure: What's coming?
Shure:  这是土豆啊
Shure: Is this a potato?
Shure:  不好意思哈哈哈
Shure: Sorry, haha.
Katrina: 窝窝头是不是
Katrina: Is that cornbread?
Shure:  是窝窝头还是土豆
Shure: Is it cornbread or a potato?
Lucia: 窝窝头吧
Lucia: It's cornbread.
Shure:  流心包
Shure: It's a lava bun.
Shure: 私密马赛
Shure: Excuse me.
Katrina: 柠檬
Katrina: Lemon.
Shure: 柠檬肯定有
Shure: We definitely have lemons.
Lucia: 青柠
Lucia: Lime.
Lucia: 这个是青柠檬吗lemon
Lucia: Is this a lime or a lemon?
Katrina: 青柠更适合还是柠檬更适合
Katrina: Is lime or lemon better?
Shure: 都来
Shure: Get both.
Lucia: 都还行哎
Lucia: Both are fine.
Katrina: 哎爽快
Katrina: Great.
Katrina: 笑死这才4块6啊
Katrina: So funny, it's only 4.6 yuan.
Katrina: 这放这放饮品里是不是好喝
Katrina: This would taste good in drinks, right?
Shure: 哦小小小小青柠吧
Shure: Oh, the little lime.
Lucia: 这个对这个可以 整个放进去
Lucia: Yeah, this one works. Just put the whole thing in.
Katrina: 这好
Katrina: That's good.
Lucia: 然后普通青柠就跟你们一样切片
Lucia: Then for regular lime, just slice it like you guys do.
Shure:  lemon
Shure: Lemon.
Shure:  iwonderhow
Shure: I wonder how.
Shure: i wonder why
Shure: I wonder why
Shure: yestaday you tell me but the bule bule sky
Shure: Yesterday you told me about the blue blue sky
Shure: and all the i can see
Shure: And all that I can see
Katrina:  彩笔打孔器这玩意会有吗
Katrina: Do you think there will be a colored pencil hole puncher?
Lucia: 啦啦啦啦啦啦啦blueblue sky
Lucia: La la la la la la blue blue sky
Shure:  打孔器采纸这种
Shure: Like a hole puncher for colored paper
Shure:  文具的应该这都没有
Shure: There probably isn't any of that kind of stationery here
Katrina: 那冰块
Katrina: What about ice?
Lucia: 那些实在不行
Lucia: Those won't work
Lucia: 感觉在淘宝上买也来得及送过来
Lucia: I feel like we could still buy it on Taobao and it would arrive in time
Katrina: 这是干什么的
Katrina: What is this for?
Katrina: 打包吗他们在
Katrina: Are they packing?
Katrina: 那就没了
Katrina: Then that's it
Shure:  iwonderhow i wonder why
Shure: I wonder how, I wonder why
Katrina: 我们就主要采购酒的东西
Katrina: We're mainly shopping for drinks
Katrina: 那看看还有啥想吃的买
Katrina: Let's see if there's anything else we want to eat
Shure: 我就不信这没有桃汁吗
Shure: I can't believe there's no peach juice
Katrina: 哦饮料在这呢
Katrina: Oh, the drinks are here
Katrina:  桃汁没有我靠
Katrina: No peach juice, what the heck
Katrina:  受不了
Katrina: Can't stand it
Katrina:  哎这是葡萄汁吧
Katrina: Hey, is this grape juice?
Katrina: 我靠这也太大了
Katrina: Wow, this is huge
Katrina:  这也有葡萄汁哦
Katrina: There's grape juice here too
Katrina: 我们拿的是什么啊
Katrina: What did we pick up?
Shure:  葡萄胡萝卜
Shure: Grape and carrot
Shure: 那把这放回去吧换这个
Shure: Let's put this back and switch to that
Katrina: 我们拿瓶小的
Katrina: Let's get a smaller bottle
Katrina: 这个葡萄汁
Katrina: This grape juice
Lucia: 都行
Lucia: Either works
Katrina: 这感觉很正宗啊
Katrina: This feels really authentic
Katrina: 很浓的葡萄感觉
Katrina: Very strong grape flavor
Katrina: 为什么呢
Katrina: Why though?
Katrina:  这个啊这椰奶也太大了
Katrina: This coconut milk is huge
Katrina: 这奶大吗
Katrina: Is this milk big?
Katrina:  没有桃汁
Katrina: No peach juice
Katrina:  我也没看转一圈了
Katrina: I didn't see any after looking around
Katrina: 可乐柠檬维他葡萄汁养乐多水溶西柚味椰汁桃汁
Katrina: Coke, lemon, Vita grape juice, Yakult, water soluble grapefruit flavor, coconut juice, peach juice
Katrina:  冰
Katrina: Ice
Katrina: 打孔器彩笔
Katrina: Hole puncher, colored pencils
Katrina:  回去买打孔器材
Katrina: Let's go back and buy hole puncher supplies
Lucia: 放回去了吗已经
Lucia: Have you put it back already?
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 没了吧 没了吗j人
Shure: Is it all gone? Is there nothing left?
Katrina:  没了
Katrina: It's all gone.
Katrina:  那就找他们去
Katrina: Then let's go find them.
Shure:  走吧j人
Shure: Let's go then.
Lucia: 限时买赠 买一送一
Lucia: Limited time offer, buy one get one free.
Lucia: 哎刚好碰到你们
Lucia: Oh, just happened to run into you guys.
Katrina:  买完了
Katrina: We've finished buying.
Jake:你们
Jake: You guys...
Katrina:  有两个笔没有
Katrina: There are two pens missing.
Katrina:  没有有两
Katrina: No, there are two...
Alice:调料
Alice: Seasoning.
Jake: 买肉了吗
Jake: Did you buy meat?
Jake:火锅什么的他们要
Jake: For hotpot, they need it.
Katrina:  那去去买火锅的食材是吧
Katrina: So we need to buy hotpot ingredients, right?
Jake:那你们去吧
Jake: Then you guys go.
Alice:我们买葱蒜了
Alice: We bought green onions and garlic.
Katrina:  啊葱蒜
Katrina: Ah, green onions and garlic.
Katrina:  那我们去买火锅食材
Katrina: Then we'll go buy hotpot ingredients.
Jake:肉在那去吧
Jake: The meat is over there, go ahead.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 好那那种什么肥牛卷啥的可以
Katrina: Okay, like some kind of fatty beef rolls would be good.
Shure:  烤肉的也要买一下
Shure: Also need to buy some for BBQ.
Jake:烤肉
Jake: BBQ?
Katrina: 那个放冰箱应该可以放两天吧
Katrina: That should be fine in the fridge for two days, right?
Lucia: 呃一直得走那个牛卷
Lucia: Uh, we always need those beef rolls.
Shure:  先买火锅的食材
Shure: First, let's buy hotpot ingredients.
Katrina: 哦对因为他不在
Katrina: Oh right, because he's not here.
Jake: 先火锅吧
Jake: Hotpot first.
Jake: 烤肉是要过一阵的
Jake: BBQ will be later.
Katrina: 今晚不能吃啊
Katrina: Can't eat it tonight?
Jake:你你没炭呢还
Jake: You, you don't even have charcoal.
Jake: 他们还在买火锅
Jake: They're still buying hotpot stuff.
Lucia: 应该可以吧放两天
Lucia: It should be fine for two days, right?
Shure:  这些都美团都可以送
Shure: Meituan can deliver all of these.
Jake:一起嘛
Jake: All together.
Lucia: 放两天应该没事了
Lucia: It should be okay for two days.
Lucia: 但如果我们烧烤是最后一天烤的话
Lucia: But if we BBQ on the last day...
Jake:那都美团送的
Jake: Then Meituan will deliver everything.
Lucia: 感觉不需要今天买
Lucia: Feels like we don't need to buy it today.
Shure:  但是如的话可以先买
Shure: But if we need it, we can buy it now.
Katrina: 不搞烧烤吧
Katrina: No barbecue, right?
Katrina: 他们不是说
Katrina: Didn't they say...
Jake:肉
Jake: Meat.
Jake:放得下不小冰箱
Jake: It fits in the small fridge.
Katrina: 就买买火锅的食材
Katrina: Let's just buy hotpot ingredients.
Shure:  买火锅的肉
Shure: Buy meat for hotpot.
Jake:对对万对
Jake: Yes, yes, definitely.
Lucia: 烧烤的话最后一天才用
Lucia: We only need the barbecue for the last day.
Lucia: 对咱中间应该还会再出来
Lucia: Yes, we'll probably go out again in between.
Shure:  不咱自己偷偷吃不给他们吃
Shure: No, we'll secretly eat by ourselves and not let them have any.
Katrina: 肉肉肉肉肉
Katrina: Meat, meat, meat, meat, meat.
Lucia: 趁着他们还没起床
Lucia: While they're still asleep.
Lucia: 先下楼烤两串
Lucia: Let's go downstairs and grill a few skewers first.
Shure:  这是烤肉的吧
Shure: This is for grilling, right?
Lucia: 日式烤肉片
Lucia: Japanese-style grilled slices.
Katrina: 这能
Katrina: This can...
Katrina: 火锅要找薄一点的
Katrina: For hotpot, it needs to be thinner.
Lucia: 这个应该是涮的
Lucia: This should be for shabu-shabu.
Katrina:  我有闹钟响了
Katrina: My alarm went off.
Katrina:  吓我一跳
Katrina: Gave me a scare.
Lucia: 这到底是他们的longJackchen
Lucia: Is this really their longJackchen?
Lucia: 还是什么东西啊
Lucia: Or what is it?
Shure:  是这个吧
Shure: It's this one, right?
Shure:  我早上听得一清二楚
Shure: I heard it clearly this morning.
Lucia: 真假
Lucia: Really?
Shure:  我就知道
Shure: I just knew it.
Shure:  哪个倒霉蛋是闹钟自己没没醒
Shure: Which unlucky person had the alarm but didn't wake up?
Shure:  因为那个真的特别不容易醒
Shure: Because it's really hard to wake up to that.
Shure:  我也不知道为什么
Shure: I don't know why either.
Katrina: 我要换一个
Katrina: I need to change it.
Katrina: 拿了一盒这个再拿一盒这个
Katrina: I'll take one box of this and another of that.
Tasha: 这
Tasha: This...
Katrina:  这是上脑啊
Katrina: This is beef chuck, right?
Katrina:  上脑也是有肉吧
Katrina: Beef chuck also has meat, right?
Shure:  是啊
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 他们没拿肉吗
Katrina: Didn't they take any meat?
Shure:  拿了两盒一样的
Shure: They took two boxes of the same thing.
Shure:  没有他们没拿
Shure: No, they didn't take any.
Katrina:  不一样
Shure: 嗯 OK
Shure:  这个多少钱啊
Shure:  35块9 那好便宜
Katrina:  好贵啊
Shure:  还好 35块9
Katrina:  那可能这肉比较好吧
Shure:  换算换算过去50块钱一斤呗
Shure:  对 50块钱正常价
Katrina:  那那那个
Katrina:  吃火锅的话是不是还得买点蘸料
Shure:  对蘸料他们应该去买
Shure:  咱们买牛肉羊肉
Katrina:  以前那个什么海海底捞是不是可以送
Katrina: 他的那个蘸料过来
Katrina:  算了还是自己弄哎
Katrina:  羊肉
Katrina: 有羊肉吗
Katrina:  这都是肥牛啊
Lucia: 这是煎这也是涮
Katrina: 哦毛肚
Katrina: Oh, tripe.
Lucia: 脆毛肚
Lucia: Crispy tripe.
Shure: 冷藏储存这个要
Shure: This needs to be refrigerated.
Katrina: 神奇
Katrina: Amazing.
Katrina: 可以放哎
Katrina: Can we store it?
Shure: 咋这有冰箱
Shure: Why is there a fridge here?
Katrina: 这种东西有血
Katrina: Does this stuff have blood?
Katrina: 可以放几天吗
Katrina: Can it be stored for a few days?
Katrina: 哦 5天
Katrina: Oh, 5 days.
Katrina: 吊龙吊龙也好吃
Katrina: Beef tenderloin is also delicious.
Katrina: 但买了那个有没有虾滑哎
Katrina: But did we get shrimp paste?
Lucia: 我刚刚也想找虾滑
Lucia: I was just looking for shrimp paste.
Katrina: 是吧我吃火锅必点虾滑
Katrina: Right? I always order shrimp paste for hotpot.
Shure:  暴风吸入啊
Shure: Devour it in one go.
Katrina:  哈哈哈爽了
Katrina: Hahaha, so satisfying.
Shure:  爽
Shure: Satisfying.
Katrina:  羊肉是吗
Katrina: Is that lamb?
Shure:  中间这些冰鲜柜应该有吧嗯
Shure: There should be some in the middle of the refrigerated section, right?
Shure:  这好像是豆制品类
Shure: This seems to be tofu products.
Tasha: 好的
Tasha: Okay.
Shure:  看看有没有什么响铃之类的
Shure: Let's see if there's any ringing or something.
Shure:  那种没有可涮的
Shure: The kind that doesn't need dipping.
Lucia: 哎这有蒜蓉酱
Lucia: Hey, there's garlic sauce here.
Shure:  蒜蓉酱吃火锅用的到吗
Shure: Do we use garlic sauce for hotpot?
Katrina:  有的那个火锅店里他不是
Katrina: Some hotpot places do.
Lucia: 就是你可以往蘸料里放
Lucia: Yeah, you can put it in the dipping sauce.
Lucia: 但是咱们买这么一大瓶肯定用不完
Lucia: But buying a big bottle like this, we won't finish it.
Shure:  虾滑这呢
Shure: Here's the shrimp paste.
Katrina:  咱民宿有碗吗
Katrina: Do we have bowls at the Airbnb?
Katrina:  是不是我们的环保理念
Katrina: Is it part of our eco-friendly policy?
Lucia: 有
Lucia: Yes.
Katrina: 不允许用一次性的东西
Katrina: No disposable stuff allowed.
Lucia: 哦我们不拍到他就可以了
Lucia: Oh, we just don't film it, and it's fine.
Shure:  我们刷碗的时候就
Shure: When we're washing dishes...
Shure:  我们直接卡掉
Shure: We just cut it off.
Shure:  吃完饭就卡掉了
Shure: After eating, we cut it off.
Shure:  然后把一次性的东西扔了
Shure: Then we throw away the disposable stuff.
Shure:  但是我们吃饭的时候会拍
Shure: But we will film while eating.
Shure:  火锅旁边他肯定不敢拍
Shure: They won't dare to film near the hotpot.
Lucia: 嗯对因为有热气
Lucia: Yeah, because of the steam.
Shure:  因为有热气
Shure: Because of the steam.
Lucia: 那
Lucia: Then...
Shure:  对呃丸滑类的
Shure: Yes, uh, meatballs.
Katrina: 哎没了
Katrina: Hey, it's gone.
Shure: 这吶丸滑类的在那呢
Shure: Here, the meatballs are over here.
Katrina:  什么东西
Katrina: What?
Shure: 就是丸滑那些
Shure: The meatballs and stuff.
Shure:  这已经不在j人的
Shure: This isn't on Jake's...
Shure:  清单了他现在很苦恼
Shure: List anymore. He's very frustrated now.
Shure:  这他妈的都不在我清单里
Shure: None of this is on my list.
Shure:  你们买什么
Shure: What are you guys buying?
Shure:  冻豆腐
Shure: Frozen tofu.
Shure:  豆制品拼盘
Shure: Tofu platter.
Katrina:  火锅拼盘
Katrina: Hotpot platter.
Katrina: 这是什么黑千层
Katrina: What's this, black thousand-layer?
Katrina: 这也是吃火锅用的
Katrina: Is this for hotpot too?
Katrina:  他们是把食材任务全部交给我们了吗
Katrina: Did they leave all the ingredient tasks to us?
Katrina:  那不得考虑6人份吗
Katrina: Shouldn't we consider portions for 6 people?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Lucia: 不太确定他们买了什么呢
Lucia: Not really sure what they bought.
Lucia: 是不是一会还能再偶遇一下
Lucia: Maybe we'll bump into them again later.
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Really?
Katrina:  那他们没买食品
Katrina: They didn't buy any food.
Shure:  素菜是不是交给他们了
Shure: Did they get the vegetables?
Katrina: 素菜
Katrina: Vegetables.
Shure: 我们吃火锅吃素菜吗
Shure: Are we having vegetables with the hotpot?
Katrina: 吃吃金针菇
Katrina: Yeah, like enoki mushrooms.
Lucia: 吃一点
Lucia: Just a little bit.
Shure:  绿叶菜是不吃是吗
Shure: No leafy greens, right?
Lucia: 我有时候会要个白菜或者油麦菜
Lucia: Sometimes I order cabbage or lettuce.
Katrina: 感觉基本不吃吧
Katrina: Feels like we don't usually eat them.
Shure:  就是别人点会跟着吃两口
Shure: Only if someone else orders, we'll have a bite.
Shure:  但自己不会主动点
Shure: But we won't order them ourselves.
Katrina:  一般点莴笋
Katrina: Usually, we get asparagus lettuce.
Katrina:  笋呐什么
Katrina: Or bamboo shoots or something.
Lucia: 我也喜欢笋
Lucia: I like bamboo shoots too.
Katrina: 对吧但绿叶菜你说什么
Katrina: Right? But leafy greens, like what?
Katrina: 小青菜没有小菠菜也没有小
Katrina: No baby bok choy, no spinach.
Katrina: 走吧逛玩玩
Katrina: Let's go, keep walking around.
Katrina: 这还有一个冷藏过的
Katrina: And there's a refrigerated one too.
Katrina: 哈喽你们买那个肉制品
Katrina: Hello, did you guys get the meat products?
Tasha: 你觉得买哪个好
Tasha: Which one do you think we should get?
Shure: hello
Shure: Hello.
Katrina:  那个肉制品火锅全部就是我们管是吗
Katrina: So, we're in charge of all the meat for the hotpot?
Katrina: 那你们买了什么
Katrina: What did you guys buy?
Katrina:  青菜吗哎
Katrina: Vegetables?
Katrina: 好像没有买青菜
Katrina: Seems like you didn't get any vegetables.
Tasha: 这是你要的咖啡豆吗
Tasha: Is this the coffee beans you wanted?
Jake:买了不多就买一个
Jake: Didn't buy much, just one.
Alice: 还是这种的
Alice: It's this kind.
Jake:这个今天是他们要做上汤娃娃菜
Jake: Today, they're making baby cabbage soup.
Jake:专门给他上汤娃娃菜搞的蔬菜
Jake: Special vegetables for the baby cabbage soup.
Shure:  就是这个有点捞
Shure: It's a bit much.
Jake:应该没有别的菜了
Jake: There shouldn't be any other vegetables.
Katrina:  也就是说火锅下的菜跟
Katrina: So, the hotpot veggies...
Shure: 我不想买这个
Shure: I don't want to buy this one.
Jake:火锅没有菜
Jake: There's no food for the hotpot.
Jake:对火锅还没有菜
Jake: Yeah, there's still no food for the hotpot.
Lucia: 肉质都是我们挑
Katrina: We picked out all the meat.
Shure: 给给你买的那个条条的那种
Shure: I bought you those strip ones.
Katrina:  那我们得多加一点
Katrina: Then we need to add more.
Katrina:  感觉6个人不够吃哎
Katrina: Feels like six people won't have enough to eat.
Alice: 你买了吗
Alice: Did you buy it?
Shure: 我买了  啊 对
Shure: I bought it. Oh, yes.
Lucia: 你可以先看一下吗
Lucia: Can you check it first?
Lucia: 现在买的东西
Lucia: The stuff we bought now.
Jake:好一会我们对一下吧
Jake: Okay, let's check it later.
Jake:等他们一起对一下
Jake: Let's check it together later.
Jake:盘算一下
Jake: Do some calculations.
Katrina: 还得买两盒肉哎
Katrina: We still need to buy two more packs of meat.
Jake:他们现在在套好
Jake: They're packing it up now.
Lucia: 好奇一下你们这边的东西
Lucia: Just curious about your stuff here.
Jake:他们在研究咖啡豆
Jake: They're studying coffee beans.
Tasha: 保鲜膜
Tasha: Cling film.
Alice:保鲜膜
Alice: Cling film.
Jake:咖啡豆
Jake: Coffee beans.
Lucia: 我们刚才好像是拿了一盒速溶咖啡
Lucia: We seem to have taken a pack of instant coffee earlier.
Shure:  我跟他跟他说了
Shure: I told him.
Jake:哦速溶但是这个就慢
Jake: Oh, instant but this one is slow.
Lucia: 嗯？有泰拉
Lucia: Huh? There's Tera.
Katrina: 什么呀
Katrina: What?
Shure:  咖啡豆的话
Shure: If it's coffee beans.
Lucia: 就是这个
Lucia: It's this one.
Lucia: 好久不见了 从我回国
Lucia: Long time no see since I came back.
Katrina:  你们拿椰奶了吗
Katrina: Did you get coconut milk?
Alice:有椰子水
Alice: There's coconut water.
Shure:  购入一下
Shure: Let's purchase it.
Lucia: mitchposticks怎么还是从德国进口了
Lucia: How come Mitchposticks are still imported from Germany?
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Katrina:  我们拿椰子汁了吗
Katrina: Did we get coconut juice?
Alice: 你们需要吗
Alice: Do you need it?
Katrina:  我在想
Katrina: I'm thinking.
Katrina:  咖啡是不是可以兑一点椰子汁啊
Katrina: Can we mix some coconut juice with coffee?
Katrina:  生椰拿铁
Katrina: Fresh coconut latte.
Alice:椰奶吗
Alice: Coconut milk?
Katrina:  嗯但是那种大的咖啡
Katrina: Yeah, but the big coffee.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Okay.
Katrina:  呃椰奶是不是只能放一天
Katrina: Uh, coconut milk can only be stored for one day, right?
Alice:不开封的话可以放几天
Alice: If it's unopened, it can last a few days.
Katrina:  那就是开了那就得一天喝完呗
Katrina: So if it's opened, you have to drink it within a day?
Katrina:  我没看他那种小盒的椰树你知道吗
Katrina: I haven't seen those small cartons of coconut milk, you know?
Katrina:  他都是大盒的椰树
Katrina: They're always in large cartons.
Jake:螺蛳粉看到了
Jake: Look, there's snail noodles.
Lucia: 那个
Lucia: That one.
Jake:真的
Jake: Really.
Katrina:  你去问一下子吧你拿
Katrina: Go ask about it, will you?
Jake:我们要对一下吗
Jake: Should we check it?
Lucia: 感觉可以
Lucia: I think we can.
Jake: 好那
Jake: Alright then.
Alice:其实那个大的你开封之后放两三天
Alice: Actually, if you open the large one, it can last two or three days.
Jake:那找个地方
Jake: Let's find a place.
Lucia: 叮咚
Lucia: Ding dong.
Jake: 我们先对一下吧
Jake: Let's check it first.
Katrina: 当时谁跟我说椰奶变质了会中毒
Katrina: Someone told me if coconut milk goes bad, it can be poisonous.
Lucia: 对保鲜膜可以在超市买
Lucia: Right, you can buy plastic wrap at the supermarket.
Alice:确实
Alice: That's true.
Jake:对一下我们找一个
Jake: Let's check it out, we'll find one.
Katrina: 就不敢
Katrina: I just don't dare.
Alice:但是嗯嗯我一般一
Alice: But yeah, usually I...
Katrina: 我确实没有看见他那小盒小盒的
Katrina: I really haven't seen those small cartons.
Alice:我一般买这种大的
Alice: I usually buy the large ones.
Tasha: 买咖啡液也行 就不用咖啡粉就不用速溶咖啡调了
Tasha: Buying coffee liquid works too, no need for coffee powder or instant coffee.
Alice:之后放两三天也没事
Alice: Then store it for two or three days, it's fine.
Alice: 不用他那个变质的话会很明显
Alice: If it goes bad, it'll be very obvious.
Katrina: 要么直接叫外卖吧
Katrina: Or just order takeout directly.
Shure:  也行反正都都都行
Shure: That's fine, whatever works.
Katrina:  因为有两个东西买不到
Katrina: Because there are two things we can't buy.
Jake:都行都行反正我也不喝咖啡
Jake: Whatever works, I don't drink coffee anyway.
Shure: 那你今天
Shure: So today you...
Jake:哈哈早上不行啊
Jake: Haha, not in the morning.
Katrina: 不知道以为我们工作呢
Katrina: People might think we're working.
Jake:早上喝了一下
Jake: I had some in the morning.
Katrina: 天天买这么多咖啡
Katrina: Buying so much coffee every day.
Shure: 不行了是吧
Shure: Not working anymore, huh?
Jake:其实还好
Lucia: Actually, it's not that bad.
Katrina: 这个肉不够吧
Katrina: This meat isn't enough, right?
Katrina:  如果我6个人吃火锅的话
Katrina: If six of us are having hotpot...
Alice:肉在哪啊
Alice: Where's the meat?
Tasha: 这呢
Tasha: Here it is.
Lucia: 这里
Lucia: Here.
Katrina: 两盒牛肉
Katrina: Two boxes of beef.
Tasha: 再买点丸子和虾滑
Tasha: Let's buy some more meatballs and shrimp paste.
Katrina:  丸子买了虾滑也买了
Katrina: We've bought meatballs and shrimp paste.
Katrina:  虾滑在这哦
Katrina: The shrimp paste is here.
Lucia: 丸子虾滑
Lucia: Meatballs and shrimp paste.
Katrina:  我觉得还要拿两盒肉
Katrina:  青菜也没买哎
Katrina: We didn't buy any greens.
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: And then...
Lucia: 我们为什么买哦
Lucia: Why did we buy... oh, vegetables.
Lucia: 哦哦蔬菜是吧
Lucia: Oh, vegetables.
Lucia: 蔬菜哦新到的咸鱼土豆
Lucia: Fresh salted fish and potatoes.
Tasha: 土豆
Tasha: Potatoes.
Katrina:  你要吃土豆是吗
Katrina: Do you want to eat potatoes?
Jake: 土豆好土豆可以
Jake: Potatoes are good.
Lucia: 其实我也喜欢
Lucia: Actually, I like them too.
Katrina: 走吧那我们蔬菜买肉跟青菜
Katrina: Let's go, let's buy the vegetables, meat, and greens.
Jake:咱不是还有那个削土豆皮的那个
Jake: Don't we have that potato peeler?
Tasha: 那个不是完了小土豆皮奥
Tasha: Isn't that for small potatoes?
Tasha: 芋头没有买
Tasha: We didn't buy taro.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Shure: 芋头是啥啊
Shure: What is taro?
Lucia: 芋头放火锅吗
Lucia: Taro in hotpot?
Alice:芋头
Alice: Taro.
Tasha: 不是芋泥
Tasha: Not taro paste.
Lucia: 啊okok
Lucia: Ah, okay, okay.
Shure: 芋泥
Shure: Taro paste.
Jake:哎呀这什么东西
Jake: Oh, what's this?
Lucia: sorry没有跟上这个频道
Lucia: Sorry, I couldn't keep up.
Alice:芋头放火锅也很好吃
Alice: Taro in hotpot is delicious too.
Alice: 那个荔浦芋头
Alice: That Liupao taro
Tasha: 对我是要买荔浦芋头
Tasha: Right, I want to buy Liupao taro
Tasha: 走吧诶不对
Tasha: Let's go, wait, no
Shure: 芋芋泥能波波吗
Shure: Can we make taro puree?
Tasha: 好那我们的爆皮刀就有两用了
Tasha: Alright, then our peeler will have two uses
Shure:  芋泥能啵啵吗
Shure: Can we make taro puree?
Jake:哈哈哈走
Jake: Hahaha, let's go
Katrina: 哈哈少来这种
Katrina: Haha, stop it
Tasha: 你想吃螺蛳粉吗
Tasha: Do you want to eat snail noodles?
Lucia: 水产品
Lucia: Seafood
Lucia: 如果我们想买虾仁的话
Lucia: If we want to buy shrimp
Alice:他们买过了吗
Alice: Have they bought it?
Alice:我们菜不是在那边吗
Alice: Isn't our vegetables over there?
Tasha: 他们可能先买肉吧
Tasha: They might buy meat first
Jake: 他们买帝王蟹是吧
Jake: They are buying king crab, right?
Tasha: 这个也在资金范围内吗
Tasha: Is this within the budget?
Jake:你们买海蟹
Jake: You guys buy sea crab
Jake:哈哈不不你们买海鲜吗
Jake: Haha, no, no, are you buying seafood?
Lucia: 哇哦 我可以吃这个吗
Lucia: Wow, can I eat this?
Jake: 哈哈哈打打招呼吧
Jake: Hahaha, say hi
Katrina: 我们的预算可以吃这个吗
Katrina: Can our budget cover this?
Jake: 要不就拍一拍吧要不
Jake: Why not just take a picture?
Jake: 你好
Jake: Hello
Katrina: 2099
Lucia: 扫描一下
Lucia: Scan it
Jake: 1,699也还行吧
Jake: 1,699 is okay, right?
Alice:您好
Alice: Hello
Tasha: 那来一只吧
Tasha: Then let's get one
Lucia: 真的吗可以吃吗
Lucia: Really, can we eat it?
Lucia: 哈哈哈来一只吧
Lucia: Hahaha, let's get one
Shure:  你千万不要口嗨
Shure: Don't just talk big
Shure:  我们会当真的好不好
Shure: We'll take it seriously, okay?
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes, yes
Jake:我就说也还行
Jake: I was just saying it's okay
Jake:我没多说什么
Jake: I didn't say much
Tasha: 有没有那个转架还是干嘛
Tasha: Is there a stand or something?
Jake:哈哈哈我没哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, I didn't, hahaha
Lucia: 也还行我们就把这个也字去掉吧啊
Lucia: It's okay, let's just drop the "also"
Lucia: 把还字也去掉
Lucia: Remove the word "still" too.
Shure: 蘸料你们买了吗
Shure: Did you guys buy the dipping sauce?
Lucia: 对对对我们自动识别成型
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, we automatically recognize it.
Jake:好好
Jake: Okay, okay.
Shure:  蘸料你们买了吗
Shure: Did you guys buy the dipping sauce?
Shure: 火锅的蘸料 那一起去买一点
Shure: Hotpot dipping sauce. Let's go buy some together.
Alice:蘸料没有
Alice: We don't have dipping sauce.
Shure:  你们都吃什么碟的火锅一般
Shure: What kind of hotpot dipping sauce do you usually eat?
Alice:麻酱
Alice: Sesame paste.
Shure: 麻酱醋麻酱
Shure: Sesame paste and vinegar.
Tasha: 我要醋
Tasha: I want vinegar.
Lucia: 芝麻酱
Lucia: Sesame paste.
Lucia: 你吃什么
Lucia: What do you eat?
Lucia: 找到了啥呀
Lucia: What did you find?
Tasha: 你吃什么碟呢 醋碟
Tasha: What dipping sauce do you eat? Vinegar sauce?
Shure:  白灼汁
Shure: Boiled sauce.
Shure:  你吃火锅一般吃什么蘸料
Shure: What kind of dipping sauce do you usually eat with hotpot?
Alice:麻酱
Alice: Sesame paste.
Katrina: 我醋
Katrina: I want vinegar.
Shure:  你要你要醋
Shure: You want vinegar?
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yes.
Jake:你吃什么碟
Jake: What dipping sauce do you eat?
Lucia: 那我们现在醋和麻酱还有什么别的需要吗
Lucia: So, do we need anything else besides vinegar and sesame paste?
Katrina: 醋啊香菜
Katrina: Vinegar and cilantro.
Shure: 都是周周边
Shure: They're all nearby.
Lucia: 香菜哈哈哈
Lucia: Cilantro, haha.
Lucia: 没事我们可以切一些香菜然后
Lucia: No worries, we can chop some cilantro.
Lucia: 吃香菜的同学吃不吃香菜的同学不吃
Lucia: Those who like cilantro can eat it, those who don't can skip it.
Katrina: 看有没有小瓶醋啊
Katrina: See if there are small bottles of vinegar.
Katrina: 大瓶醋
Katrina: Or big bottles.
Lucia: 对我觉得麻酱其实也可以买小瓶
Lucia: Yeah, I think we can also buy small bottles of sesame paste.
Lucia: 嗯感觉不是很用的完的样子
Lucia: Hmm, it doesn't seem like we'll use it all up.
Katrina: 用不完多吃两顿火锅
Katrina: If we don't finish it, we can have hotpot a couple more times.
Lucia: 也可以其实火锅还挺省钱的
Lucia: That's true, hotpot is quite cost-effective.
Lucia: 嗯只要一堆食材往里一煮就好了哈
Lucia: Hmm, just throw a bunch of ingredients in and cook it, right?
Jake: 买点方便面吧
Jake: Let's buy some instant noodles.
Jake: 算了算了哈哈哈
Jake: Forget it, forget it, hahaha.
Katrina:  后面两天经费不足
Katrina: The budget is tight for the next two days.
Katrina:  天天方便面
Katrina: Instant noodles every day.
Katrina: 找到醋了吗
Katrina: Did you find the vinegar?
Jake:干啥去啦
Jake: Where did you go?
Shure:  你好调料的那些在哪里
Shure: Hi, where are the condiments?
Shure:  蘸料啊好嘞
Shure: Dipping sauce? Okay.
Katrina:  前边右边
Katrina: In the front, to the right.
Katrina:  这是韩国的那种烧酒对吗
Katrina: This is the Korean soju, right?
Lucia: 应该是
Alice: I need konjac.
Lucia: 唉我们又绕回这个
Lucia: Oh, we're back to this again.
Katrina: 呵呵我妈很喜欢火锅里下粉丝哦
Katrina: Haha, my mom loves putting vermicelli in hot pot.
Lucia: 这个保鲜膜他们买了吗一次性手套
Lucia: Did they buy cling film and disposable gloves?
Katrina: 好像没听到他们买
Katrina: I don't think I heard them buy it.
Lucia: 保鲜膜刚才他们买了吗
Lucia: Did they buy cling film just now?
如果没有的话我觉得咱们可以拿一个
If not, I think we can grab one.
Katrina:  可以拿一个
Katrina: We can grab one.
Katrina:  然后在结账的地方发现买了再放
Katrina: And if we find they bought it at checkout, we'll put it back.
Katrina: 再放回去吗
Katrina: Put it back?
Lucia: 也可以要哪种
Lucia: That's fine too, which kind?
Lucia: 有加厚是这种普通的啊
Lucia: There's the thicker one or the regular one.
Lucia: 点段式免刀撕
Lucia: Perforated for easy tearing.
Lucia: 还有这种
Lucia: And this kind.
Shure: 没有更小一点的醋类
Shure: Don't they have smaller bottles of vinegar?
Lucia: 底下好像是保鲜袋
Lucia: The bottom looks like storage bags.
Lucia: 咱还剩保鲜膜
Lucia: We still have cling film.
Shure:  醋只有这么大的了
Shure: The vinegar only comes in this size.
Shure:  平时会当饮料喝吗
Shure: Do you usually drink it like a beverage?
Lucia: 我不会我
Lucia: I don't, I...
Shure: 可恶 居然没有山西的人
Shure: Darn, no one here from Shanxi.
Lucia: 不过醋确实一般只有这个大瓶
Lucia: But vinegar usually only comes in big bottles.
Lucia: 小瓶的太难找了
Lucia: Small bottles are hard to find.
Katrina:  你们还要买什么麻酱
Katrina: Do you guys still need to buy sesame paste?
Shure:  你平时不蘸麻酱啊
Shure: You usually don't dip in sesame paste?
Katrina: 我不蘸
Katrina: I don't dip.
Katrina:  我是那湖南口味
Katrina: I have a Hunan taste.
Katrina:  酸辣口味
Katrina: Sour and spicy taste.
Katrina: 我尝了
Katrina: I tried.
Katrina: 我不是来几次北京我吃那麻酱涮肉吗
Katrina: Didn't I eat sesame paste when I came to Beijing a few times?
Katrina:  不下饭
Katrina: It doesn't go with rice.
Katrina:  就是我发现南北最大的明显
Katrina: I found that the biggest difference between the north and south
Katrina: 最大的差别就是吃不吃麻酱
Katrina: is whether you eat sesame paste or not.
Katrina:  我那山东舍友也吃麻酱
Katrina: My roommate from Shandong eats sesame paste.
Katrina:  然后我们其他几个舍友都是四川
Katrina: And the rest of us roommates are from Sichuan.
Lucia: 这个是什么呀
Lucia: What's this?
Katrina:  江西的就孤立他
Katrina: The one from Jiangxi is isolated.
Katrina:  就是
Katrina: Right.
Katrina:  你知道我们那鸳鸯锅就中间这么小
Katrina: You know our mandarin duck pot has a small middle section.
Katrina:  是那个清清汤
Katrina: It's the clear soup.
Shure: 清汤
Shure: Clear soup.
Lucia: 哎同志们
Lucia: Hey guys,
Lucia: 这里有这个海底捞花生芝麻酱蘸料啊
Lucia: there's this Haidilao peanut sesame paste dipping sauce here.
Lucia: 我们是不是可以买两两3包这个
Lucia: Should we buy two or three packs of this?
Lucia: 嗯嗯会小一些吧感觉
Lucia: Hmm, it might be a bit less, I think.
Lucia: 说不定买3包就跟买一瓶价格差不多
Lucia: Maybe buying three packs is almost the same price as a bottle.
Katrina: 不浪费嘛
Katrina: It won't be wasteful.
Katrina: 我们环保一点
Katrina: We'll be more eco-friendly.
Lucia: 也是
Lucia: True.
Shure: 这是需要泄的还是什么
Shure: Is this the kind that needs to be diluted or what?
Katrina: 香菇酱也行哎
Katrina: Mushroom sauce is also fine.
Lucia: 什么叫泄
Lucia: What do you mean by diluted?
Katrina: 直接挤出来就能蘸吧
Katrina: Just squeeze it out and dip it.
Shure: 啊不是不是稠的那种
Shure: No, it's not the thick kind.
Shure: 然后需要卸一下
Shure: You need to dilute it.
Lucia: 卸什么意思
Lucia: What does dilute mean?
Shure:  就是拿水
Shure: Just with water.
Katrina: 卸是什么啊
Katrina: What does dilute mean?
Shure: 稀释
Katrina: It means to thin it.
Lucia: OK
Lucia: OK.
Lucia: 我感觉可以用这个或者看看有没有别的
Lucia: I think we can use this or see if there's anything else.
Katrina:  天都是麻酱
Katrina: Everything is sesame paste.
Lucia: 这里还有油碟
Lucia: Here's still some oil dip.
Katrina: 拿一罐吧
Katrina: Grab a can.
Shure: 油碟
Shure: Oil dip.
Katrina: 他们两个女生
Katrina: Those two girls.
Lucia: 油碟要么
Lucia: Want some oil dip?
Katrina: 哪的呀
Katrina: Where is it from?
Shure: 问了都是吃醋和吃香菜
Shure: I asked, and it's either vinegar or cilantro.
Lucia: 他们俩哪的来着
Lucia: Where are they from again?
Katrina: 就一个是海南的
Katrina: One is from Hainan.
Lucia: 他是家在海南吗
Lucia: Is his home in Hainan?
Lucia: 他在海南上学是不是
Lucia: Does he go to school in Hainan?
Lucia: 是是吗
Lucia: Is that right?
Shure: 我刚才问了一下
Shure: I just asked.
Lucia: 对他好像是在海南上学
Lucia: Yeah, he seems to be studying in Hainan.
Shure: 不是吃醋就是吃芝麻酱
Shure: It's either vinegar or sesame paste.
Katrina:  好那就分为两大流派
Katrina: Okay, then we have two main factions.
Shure:  走没了吧
Shure: Let's go, it's all gone, right?
Katrina:  拿两盒肉
Katrina: Grab two boxes of meat.
Katrina: 肉不够啊
Katrina: We don't have enough meat.
Lucia: 肉不够啊咋们
Lucia: We don't have enough meat, what do we do?
Katrina: 调料差不多
Katrina: The seasoning is almost enough.
Lucia: 咱们6个人如果
Lucia: If all six of us...
Lucia: 都在咱们这里拿着
Lucia: Keep it with us.
Katrina: 我看他们买了葱
Katrina: I saw they bought green onions.
Lucia: 啊还有这种的
Lucia: Ah, they bought that too.
Katrina:  我不敢吃这玩意啊
Katrina: I don't dare to eat that stuff.
Shure:  觉得可怕
Shure: It looks scary.
Katrina: 是是挺可怕的呀
Katrina: Yeah, it is pretty scary.
Katrina: 感觉他的脑袋一口
Katrina: Feels like its head would burst with one bite.
Shure:  完了跟丢了去搜寻吧
Shure: Alright, we lost track, let's go search.
Katrina: 一口爆汁那脑袋
Katrina: One bite and its head would burst.
Shure:  巡回猎犬
Shure: Like a hunting dog.
Katrina:  又去那个拿肉哎
Katrina: They went to get meat again.
Katrina:  好像确实没买羊肉哈
Katrina: Seems like we didn't buy lamb.
Katrina:  都是牛肉
Katrina: It's all beef.
Shure:  对咱没买羊肉
Shure: Yeah, we didn't buy lamb.
Shure:  都是羊肉的
Shure: It's all lamb.
Katrina:  但是那个柜子里好像也
Katrina: But in that cabinet, it seems like...
Katrina: 都是牛肉
Katrina: It's all beef.
Lucia: 对基本都是牛肉哎
Lucia: Yeah, basically all beef.
Katrina:  上次我去广东那边玩
Katrina: Last time I went to Guangdong for fun.
Katrina: 我看他们吃那个吊龙
Katrina: I saw them eating that "Diaolong."
Lucia: 嗯哼
Lucia: Uh-huh.
Katrina: 吊龙好像还可以
Katrina: "Diaolong" seems okay.
Lucia: 什么叫吊龙是一种牛的部位
Lucia: What's "Diaolong"? It's a part of the cow.
Katrina: 牛的一个部位
Katrina: A part of the cow.
Katrina: 不是吃那个潮汕牛肉火锅吗
Katrina: Isn't it for the Chaoshan beef hotpot?
Katrina: 他每一个都划的很细致
Katrina: They cut each piece very meticulously.
Katrina: 再拿一盒吊龙
Katrina: Then take another box of "Diaolong."
Katrina: 再去拿拿羊
Katrina: Then go get lamb.
Shure:  我找到了
Shure: I found it.
Lucia: 什么羊羊肉吗
Lucia: What, lamb, lamb meat?
Shure:  我刚才买了一啊
Shure: I just bought some.
Shure:  这是牛肉丸啊
Shure: These are beef balls.
Katrina: 够了 5盒肉
Katrina: Enough, five boxes of meat.
Shure:  够了卧槽
Shure: Enough, damn.
Katrina: 五六盒肉
Katrina: Five or six boxes of meat.
Shure:   1盒两盒3盒4盒5盒5盒肉
Shure: One box, two boxes, three boxes, four boxes, five boxes, five boxes of meat.
Katrina:  还有虾滑两盒
Katrina: And two boxes of shrimp paste.
Katrina: 两盒牛肚
Katrina: Two boxes of beef tripe.
Katrina: 够了
Katrina: That's enough.
Lucia: 对虾滑两盒牛肚还有个丸子
Lucia: Yes, shrimp paste, two boxes, beef tripe, and some meatballs.
Katrina: 就青青菜没买
Katrina: We didn't buy any greens.
Katrina: 就吃豆制品
Katrina: Just eat tofu products.
Katrina: 那就吃豆制品呗那还有新疆
Katrina: Then let's just eat tofu products, there's also...
Katrina: 叫什么金针菇那种
Katrina: What's it called, enoki mushrooms.
Lucia: 哎呦sorry
Lucia: Oh, sorry.
Lucia: 青菜我投一票是
Lucia: I vote for greens.
Lucia: 生菜好了还有人想吃
Lucia: Lettuce, is anyone else up for it?
Katrina:  还有人想吃土豆夹子啊
Katrina: Does anyone want potato wedges?
Katrina: 可以啊你买呗
Katrina: Sure, you can buy it.
Tasha: 你跟他们说我们买了土豆
Tasha: Tell them we bought potatoes.
Tasha: 还有豆制品豆腐什么
Tasha: And tofu products, like tofu.
Tasha: 豆腐的都买了
Tasha: We bought all the tofu.
Katrina: 那我们把豆制品要放了吗
Katrina: So, should we put the tofu products?
Alice: 买了魔芋
Alice: We bought konjac.
Lucia: 我们也买了豆腐好像
Lucia: We also bought tofu, I think.
Alice:买了什么豆腐
Alice: What kind of tofu did you buy?
Shure: 我们买了一个什么
Shure: What did we buy?
Shure:  豆腐什么
Shure: Some kind of tofu.
Shure:  4拼这种豆制品拼盘
Shure: A platter with four kinds of tofu products.
Alice:哦不一样的东西
Alice: Oh, different things.
Katrina: 你这个你这个是做什么的啊
Katrina: What is this for?
Tasha: 你这个是干的
Tasha: This one is dry.
Tasha: 这是鲜的啊
Tasha: This one is fresh.
Tasha: 鲜豆腐
Tasha: Fresh tofu.